pass voil c'est ça donc donc c'est pas
sur pas sur l'pecteur qui r vraiment en
fonction de Jie d'accord Mo j'aime bien
les films qui temps une histoire et qui
en même temps montre un décor or là avec
Bordeaux et le Médoc il y a une espèce
de sentiment très très homogène sur une
certaine idée comme ça de la province en
France un côté un peu bloqué parce qu'il
y a plein de vestiges du passé et puis
surtout dans ce film là qui à la fin se
termine au Canada pour avoir une rupture
totale c'est-à-dire d'un seul coup une
espèce de sauvagerie une espèce de deux
mesures comme ça qui va faire un
contraste avec tout le reste du film qui
va se passer à Bordeaux et dans le et
dans le MOC voilà
non c'est mon deuxè enfin mais c'est pas
mon mon deuxème film j'ai fait beaucoup
de films au
CanadaUn l'autre et j d'accord voil ça
c'est bon pour leè de séquence qu'
prendra après je crois le petit coup de
salut sec poli maisid et à ce momentl ça
permet à de mettre toi exactement vous
au point de vue sujet le metteur en
scène nous a demandé surtout de pas en
parler parce que c'est un sujet comme on
dit à suspense et pour employer un Fran
anglais je dirais c'est un
triller et je crois en tout cas que la
le problème qui sera posé au spectateurs
sera un problème assez original qu'on a
pour ainsi dire jamais vu à ma
connaissance jamais vu à
l'écran